c'est le samedi matin c'est mon moment
épicerie le samedi parce que ça nous
laisse l'heureuse la fin de semaine pour
cuisiner je vais tout le temps la même
épicerie avec quatre enfants la maison
je travaille ont des activités je
réponds loisir de me promener des pistes
en épicerie mais
combien vous dépenser d'argent à
l'épicerie par semaine ce départ mais je
dire autour de 3 300 350 par semaine et
on mange de la viande d'âne à tous les
repas si je regarde dans un genre de 15
20 livres de viande par semaine que je
fais plus moyen de 5 $ la livre jeter ça
me fait quelque part entre 75 100
dollars sûrement 300 donc le pour
l'instant vous n'avez pas l'impression
que vous pouvez avoir un panier
d'épicerie qui coûte moins cher pense
vraiment pas pouvoir diminuer la à pagny
égal je pense que j'ai le meilleur prix
marie hélène n'a pas tort de penser
qu'elle épargne au maximum elle cuisine
tous les repas de la famille et achètent
très peu d'aliments transformés
[Musique]
en 2021 le prix de la viande a augmenté
à un rythme jamais vu depuis 2000 kent
on est vu le prix du poulet et du boeuf
bondir de 10% et celui du véhicule de 20
pour sa
part j'arrive en le sésame qui on est
triste à
chanter
sous un dopage rencontre des familles au
quotidien pour les aider à faire une
épicerie nutritives et économique
aujourd'hui c'est la famille de marie
hélène qui bénéficiera de son expertise
comme ça t'as pas de perdre la majorité
des individus consomment trop de viande
en général
si on suit l'assiette équilibrée du
guide alimentaire canadien
donc il ya seulement un quart de la
state qui devrait il me protège à peu
près quelle quantité de viande ce calcul
par un peu tard et là bas pour toute la
famille se serait comme un terrible
événement dépendamment ça pourrait
vouloir dire que la quantité protéine
est un petit peu trop élevé c'est pas
problématique mais c'est sûr que ça
coûte beaucoup plus cher à chaque fois
que tu en mets un peu plus dans
l'assiette et dans le fond on pense
qu'on a besoin de beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de protéines légumes et tous
les rapports ses nièces par
s'additionner qui souvent hommage deux
fois plus de protéines que qu'est-ce
qu'on a réellement besoin dans une
journée donc pour économiser un premier
calcul qu'on pourrait faire manger moins
de viande
c'est tout
[Musique]
néanmoins une protéine dans un aigu
menace que dans un piège donc en faut un
peu plus dans son rapport c'est sûr que
pour garder une bonne proportion de
protéines elle est très importante pour
le corps humain mais on pourrait y aller
avec des produits plus végétarien il ya
différentes façons dont les paris qui
peut que te revoilà textures variées
parce que si on fait vraiment trois
repas par semaine et j'ai fait le calcul
avec les heurts avec les légumineuses et
avec le tofu jeu sans remplaçant sert
pas là on économise jusqu'à 12 $ par
semaine ce qui donne à peu près 140 à
650 dollars par un inconnu juste trois
repas par semaine
beaucoup plus faire à peu près trois
fois le prix à condition de se tenir
loin des produits ultra transformer
comme des saucisses ou des boulettes
végétalienne qui coûte aussi sinon plus
chers que les produits à la viande parce
qu'ils ont et des produits qui va
intéresser ces jeux qu'on trouve ici
donc la protéine végétale textures et
c'est la faille de soya dont on a
extrait l'huile pour faire de l'huile de
soya une fois les hydrater ca c'est
assez incroyable la texture à se
méprendre à de la viande hachée
tout ce qui est avec de la viande hachée
des crs est là c'est pas facile
d'utiliser de la protéine végétale
textures et quand calé réhydrater alors
quelque chose d'un peu spongieux on peut
quand la bernache et
suzanne propose un mélange attaque au
motif bien moins cheap éviter un
coupable en est presque cuites le
sillage une chose importante si on veut
que ça remplace une recette qui goûte la
viande ça serait de mettre des
ingrédients qui va remplacer semoule
lassaussois cherche ailleurs sechin cela
serait quelque chose d'intéressant donc
un bouillon de boeuf ou de légumes cat
ajoute un peu de sauce ou deux manches à
rien marc que tu vas mettre parce qu'il
ya un côté qui rappelle la viande sinon
une sauce barbecue cutter dans le frigo
autre suggestion des bâtons te fut donc
le c'est vraiment de faire débat tenait
avec le tuba sur la banc
un autre truc de suzanne avec le tofu et
de le défaire en plus ou moins gros
morceau à la main les enrobés de fécule
de maïs puis les arroser d'huile cela
peut remplacer le poulet dans une
recette est asiatique injustes a ajouté
ça avec des oignons verts puis de sa
durée et légumes à côte et europe1 fr
après ces quelques conseils le moment de
vérité avec la famille les bâtonnets de
te fut d'abord
[Musique]
et
c est ce que pour vous est-ce que ça
goûte bon le bout 5 puis la texture est
ce que c'est agréable à manger qu'à
partir de là que ce soit et de la viande
ou pas de la viande si c'est bon c'est
agréable de manger où ils vont embarquer
autour des tacos maintenant moi je
trouve que la viande est tous pareils
est-ce qu'à göteborg oui ouais ok moi
j'ai touché par balle à la texture
[Musique]
est au bout
parce que vous excuser assaisonner puis
tout se vend aussi pas que j'allais bien
à sézanne et approuve ou demander ces
allemands ont voté
dans ma ville il ya
une nouvelle étude de l'université
d'oxford en angleterre confirme aussi
qu'on peut facilement économiser en
diminuant notre consommation de viande
et même réduire notre facture de 30 % si
on les élimine carrément sans les
capable de bien les nourrir que em ce
qu'ils ont l'info ça coûte moins cher
c'est sûr qu'on embarque y aller
graduellement
penser que des fois dans la salle d'à
côté on peut mettre un peu de fromage ou
si on marche quelque chose asiatiques on
écrase des arachides puis on mélange un
peu dans un bar à salade il ya beaucoup
de façons de venir pimpé notre pauvre en
protéines pour que ça coûte moins cher
[Musique]